Speaker 1: let's try. Gee, I hope this is correct.
Jerry from Atlanta, is that how I pronounce it?
Speaker 3: Programs in gyro gyro format with.
Speaker 1: A welcome gyro payload. I apologize.
Speaker 3: Very good. So I was in an argument
with the student and I was telling him how the
burden of proof is on the people claiming
that the election is false. And he made the
point about how people on the right, those don't
trust the elections. And I told him the reason
is because political figures like Trump tell them
that they can't trust it. Correct. And he brought
up the point how like Trump was in support of the
vaccine, he was telling his supporters to get it,
but they didn't really like blindly
follow him on that issue. I didn't
know how to counter. So I was trying
to ask like how you would counter that.
Speaker 1: It doesn't it doesn't need to be
countered. I mean, it's just there are two
different things. So on the vaccines, the
issue was Trump initially convinced some
people on vaccines by saying he developed them
okay. But then the rollout of the vaccines was
mostly under Joe Biden. So then a lot of them
were able to kind of off ramp by saying, well.
It's not it's less about the vaccines, per se.
Which Trump did do a good job in developing.
But it's about how they're being forced upon me
by Joe Biden. So for a lot of it, it was just a
different situation when it comes to the election
stuff. They got the idea that it was stolen from
the things Trump said and Mike Pillow and Sidney
Powell and Rudy Giuliani. I mean, where else would
they get it? Where else would they get it? And
then on the vaccine thing. If you present them
with what what we're talking about here, a lot
of them would say, well, I was able to do my own
research on the vaccines. Like, the research is a
joke and it's nonsense. But when it comes to the
election stuff, it's not about research they
did. It's just quite literally the stuff that
Trump and others have been saying. So I don't even
really get the analogy, one of these kind of weird
analogies that doesn't really make any sense.
Speaker 3: Got you. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you very
much for the call. Appreciate hearing
from our friends in Georgia. Remember
to vote. Remember to vote in Georgia.